tension is palpable in the European
quarter in Brussels the army and police
still man the entrance to the
underground stations fewer people than
normal are traveling by metro shitbird
I'm afraid that's all voila I'm taking
the metro now no it's absolutely fine
with me no problem whatsoever I feel
secure for me is the first time i take
this metro after one week and it was
very hard i just pass through malbec and
it's very hard it's very sad and very
difficult moments the metro now stops
again in the European quarter but not at
the next station on 13 people died here
in mel back when a suicide bomber
detonated his vest in the train just
after it pulled into the tunnel to other
suicide bombers killed 19 people at
Brussels Airport a search is now
underway for a fourth accomplice a man
wearing a hat captured on CCTV at the
airport he was apparently unable to
detonate his explosive device the
airport is still closed off but within
the building investigations are largely
complete 800 stuff has volunteered for
test runs if this goes smoothly the
International Airport zaventem could
reopen soon it's the first step towards
some kind of normality though security
will continue to be high when flight
traffic resumes large traces of the
highly explosive material tatp were
found inside this house where the
terrorists constructed their bombs
neighbors say they had no idea what was
going on inside and like everyone else
in Brussels they would most like to
forget the horrific events that took
place in their city